a new british survey which is like a
regular survey but with bad teeth
finds that young people want to ban
phone calls in the office because they
find them too aggressive and
confrontational
the same reason shannon breem was banned
from walmart
75 percent of office workers said they
prefer communicating via email or social
media which they find less stressful
and easier for sending pics
here's mine
stick van dyke
dick york
my favorite be bewitched and that's dick
sergeant the second dick uh from
bewitched
both ended tragically apparently the
desire to ban calls is driven by the
under 40 millennial and gen z crowd who
prefer texting instead and one in 10
admitted they go out of their way to
avoid face-to-face contact in killmeat's
case it rises to 10 out of 10.
all this is related to the rise of
technology reducing our verbal
communication skills but the guy behind
the survey warned it's not just young
people avoiding calls adding quotes
while younger office workers clearly
prefer messaging to talking we also
found that across age groups there's a
feeling that phone calls have the
potential to quickly becoming
confrontational you know we asked him to
clarify but he called us jerks and hung
up
still if someone you don't like calls
you there's an easy solution for
everyone
man the f up
sorry person the f up
grandma show him how it's done
i got so much to do
yeah what do you want
don't laugh harley and i ain't got time
for that
all right
goodbye
she does that to me every day does she
wow calls me come come so i have to do
this i have to do that i did this and i
don't want to know that all you are
doing
wow you know kat it's amazing what hair
and makeup does to you before we get to
work
that is true
[Laughter]
can you
speak for all millennials and genzir's
cat everywhere what the hell is your
problem with confrontation
oh i
ca phone calls are confrontational
though they are aggressive
i don't like when somebody calls me i'm
like why is someone calling my text
message machine i assume somebody died
that's true so what i do i don't what
what i do is i don't answer i wait a few
minutes and then i text hey what's up
yeah and you're hoping it's not really
really bad well because why are you just
calling me like i have to prepare for
that yeah and also but you know what's
scarier than that though is the text um
we need to talk about something yeah
that's i have something yeah yeah yeah
why'd you just punch me in the face
exactly
you know uh tyrus you're in the office
on the 21st floor just next to judge
jeanine do you find it weird
where's this guy you find it weird in
the office that you still have an office
desk phone
each one of us has a desk phone have you
ever used it
no uh
well no that's not true um usually when
judging comes by i grab it yes right now
what's going
on because
chances are she wants me to move or lift
something
no she wants to ask you how you feel
about a certain issue
criticize you know if you picked up
you'd feel better you know she's
she's like the grandma i never asked for
um
yeah you know we're just brittle it's
brittle no one wants accountability
they're afraid of phone calls it's your
job it's not at home if you don't want a
phone call at home that's fine but if
you're customer service yeah you gotta
answer the phone yeah you want a text
message so you get back to when you feel
like it or an email when they'd be like
hey i emailed three times about getting
this fixed oh i'm sorry i must not have
got it can let me check my spam so it's
you're gonna end up calling anyways
because they're just too lazy to do
anything like what's going to happen if
something goes wrong yeah if the world
stops
well then you can call me oh then
i do love i do love customer chats
isn't that great because what
like when you cuss when you're on
seamless your food didn't arrive and you
go home you write a scathing message i
go where's my tacos
adam i hate young people and i suspect
i'm not alone on this where do you fall
in this world
i relate to it i hate phone calls myself
but it's not so much about the
confrontational aspect i don't mind
talking to people in person or texting
they just feel intrusive like talk to me
right now
and it's like well maybe i don't want to
talk to you right now when i was at
ellen my voicemail on my phone it said
you've reached adam i don't like phone
calls or voicemails so don't leave one
just text me and i would just never
answer my phone there you go
and i avoid them but where it's really
hard is in relationships because i don't
like talking on the phone at all right
and girls i've dated will get offended
by that i'll have to explain like it's
not that i don't want to talk to you on
the phone it's that i don't want to talk
to anyone including you on the phone
[Laughter]
you're a hopeless you're a man exactly
did it work the relationship ended
[Applause]
i was going to try i was going to try
that yeah
you know uh
julie that is your name right i remember
well
yeah
that now we believe that a phone call is
intrusive whereas
what we haven't really changed 20 years
ago 30 years ago the phone rang you
picked it up right right now we're just
like
you know yeah it's star 69 yeah oh yeah
i mean that's a love star
69 huh yeah no 69 was not as sexy as you
think it is
yeah
um so i am you know only a couple years
away from being a millennial obviously
so i can speak to the fact that i'm
almost 100 calls yeah screw you
i hate you
that also doesn't happen
it doesn't make sense i know
mathematically doesn't work a thousand i
just masked you again
i'm sorry i hate phone calls so if you
call me you better be dying and if i
like even my mom she will call me and
the whole thing i'd never i send her to
voicemail even my mother but i'll text
her back and i'll be like everything
okay so i want to make sure she's not
having a heart attack but at the same
time don't call me unless you've made a
reservation and then my other thing is
um so to avoid small talk in person so
as much as i hate phone calls i would
walk through the lobby of this building
back in the blackberry days right like
one phone here one phone like look as
unapproachable as possible so you can't
stop me and talk to me so i'd be like
madly texting and on the phone at the
same time uh did barry ever get the
message no
no you know
stupid joke
you know um
i'm glad you enjoyed it
he's the only one laughing company
phones company phones people don't
understand about company votes to how
dirty they are right how dirty that when
i worked at rodale in allentown
pennsylvania they were having problems
with their phones they opened the phones
up the tech came out and said there were
nests of cockroaches living inside your
phone oh no i know
i love telling people that story
and on that note up next
that was a big company not anymore i
don't know where it is
why jesse skipped carbs during his time
behind bars hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else